I'm Danica Patrick and I'm pretty
intense I'm incredibly optimistic that
the ending arbitration act of sexual
harassment is going to pass which will
give women the voice that they need to
not be forced into that secret chamber
of arbitration I really feel it's like
the final part of the tipping point of
the revolution because when you when you
leave the power dynamic like this where
you have the perpetrator with the hand
way up high mm-hmm because the woman's
down here because he knows she's
silenced mm-hmm right
you suddenly give her a voice and look
what happens now she's up on the same
playing field and that changes the
entire dynamic within the workplace yeah
it might even encourage this person to
not sexually harass to begin right so I
think it's it's a crucial part of this
equation and by the way my bill is
bipartisan because after covering
politics for almost 30 years
I realized that unless it is bipartisan
it's never gonna pass right so the scope
is very limited it's small it's it's
enough for Republicans who tend to not
be in favor of this to get on board I
have a bipartisan coalition in the house
and in the Senate and I remain
incredibly optimistic that we're going
to get this done for women what is the
downside to why it wouldn't be passed oh
gosh we have organizations like the
National Retail Association and the
Chamber of Commerce working against us
because they feel that it will open up
the floodgates for frivolous lawsuits
but the beauty of my bill is that it's
only about harassment it's only about
harassment so unless you have stuff to
cover up why are you against it yeah I
agree
what what advice would you have for
women that might be or a man who might
be in a scenario where they are
uncomfortable and in my mind that's the
great question is what's the line when
is the line crossed and so number one
how do you know when the line is crossed
and then what is your
vice if you really feel like it has been
so there are two forms of sexual
harassment in the workplace one's pretty
easy to discern it's quid pro quo I've
been hearing a lot about that in the
real world with politics but it
essentially means you know sleep with me
for the promotion or your fire and you'd
be surprised how much that still goes on
that obvious a woman reached out to me
who I included in my book who simply
asked for a promotion in radio and her
boss just two years ago asked her to get
up on the desk and spread him was so
joking no like was this nope is a real
question oh no and this is that's that
is a typical story that I hear there's
no gray in any of that that's pretty
black and white that's quid pro quo the
other definition of sexual harassment is
a hostile work environment and that's
where subjectivity comes in because what
I might think is hostile you might not
so if there's an off-color joke or
there's a hey you know I really like
your boobs in that dress we know that's
wrong right but some person might not be
offended by that but but another person
might so that's where the issue is
allowed to become more difficult because
now you have people saying things like
well I can't even compliment a woman on
her blue dress and and I say to that no
you can still say hey I like your hair
or I like your dress nobody's gonna sue
you over that you know it's kind of a
cop-out
as long as these really incredibly
horrible things are still happening and
being said to women I don't think we
should worry so much about the
subjective nature of it because the quid
pro quo stuff is going on every single
day in a ton of workplaces and that's
why we need to continue the national
dialogue about it because we need to
hold people accountable for this for
this kind of behavior and take away the
myths that have surrounded this and
subjugated women and kept them down for
so long where they didn't feel like they
could speak up because what happens to
them when they do they're promptly
blacklisted demoted and fire
[Music]